[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we've seen an awful lot
of change during the two years Trump has
been present American politics has been
completely reordered but also the
American media has changed forever news
organizations that seem like a big deal
just five years ago are now extinct some
of them are totally forgotten those the
remain have either degraded themselves
beyond recognition like The New Yorker
or they've been purchased by Jeff Bezos
to conduct unregistered lobbying for
amazon.com like the Washington Post it's
hard to remember that not so long ago
America had prestige media outlets
Harvard graduates literally went to work
for Newsweek rather than private equity
not anymore
Teen Vogue now has a new division and so
does a new york-based
cat blog called BuzzFeed if you're an
affluent single person and a gentrifying
part of Brooklyn who likes cats
and of course that's redundant because
they all like cats then you know and you
love BuzzFeed when a BuzzFeed headline
commands you to quote stop everything
and watch this cat who loves the ocean
you do you stop everything you watch
that cat when BuzzFeed offers one of its
trademark cat quizzes you dutifully take
the quiz what kind of personality does
your cat actually have or how cat are
you take this quiz meow you think you
know a lot about cats
BuzzFeed knows more on all questions
feline BuzzFeed is the final authority
but what happens when BuzzFeed tries to
do real news well in early 2017 we found
out the site released the now famous
Trump dossier was a catalog of salacious
and unverified gossip financed by the
DNC originally about president elect
Trump many other news outlets nearly all
of them anti Trump had seen the dossier
but they passed on it it was just too
irresponsible to run but not BuzzFeed
they thought it was perfect Wow
so they ran it two years later the
BuzzFeed dossier has come to define the
entire Trump Russia collusion conspiracy
tale the problem is a lot of the dossier
is pretty clearly on
for example one of the key claims in the
dossier that BuzzFeed ran is that Trump
attorney Michael Cohen held secret
meetings with Russian agents in Prague
they never offered any evidence that
that happened there never was any
evidence and then finally last week
Michael Cohen himself confirmed it never
happened you have been to Prague
I've never been to Prague never I've
never been to the Czech Republic
you might bounce my time well so that
seems like a pretty big development two
years ago BuzzFeed told us you remember
it we did a show on it the michael cohen
held a secret meeting with russian spies
in prague we've been hearing about that
ever since in Congress and on cable news
we have in fact halted the normal
workings of government in part because
of that meeting now it turns out it
never took place so it's not a small
thing to learn from Michael Cohen how
did BuzzFeed cover this latest stunning
development well they didn't cover it
they ignored it completely as a tonight
BuzzFeed was broening instead a story
entitled 21 completely life-changing
things you can make in a waffle maker
there was nothing about the non-existent
Michael Cohen Russian spy meeting in
Prague if you only read BuzzFeed you
would never know that that story was
false well apparently a lot of people in
media only read BuzzFeed and not simply
for its lavish cat coverage this January
BuzzFeed published a story with this
sentence quote President Donald Trump
directed his longtime attorney Michael
Cohen to lie to Congress about
negotiations to build a Trump Tower in
Moscow and quote buzz he'd prevented no
presented no evidence to show that that
was actually true just unnamed sources
but it didn't matter the cat lovers on
cable news went crazy this it would be
certainly a bombshell information speeds
latest bombshell report White House is
slamming a bombshell report by BuzzFeed
with a bombshell report from BuzzFeed
the BuzzFeed bombshell is true bombshell
report it was really a bombshell and
actually in some sense it was the claim
was anyway directing someone to lie
under oath is a felony and it ought to
be had this been true the trump
presidency likely would have ended and
for good reason legitimate reason but it
wasn't
instead it was a lot like the claim that
I don't know cats suck the breath from
babies or that he black cat brings bad
luck
it was a wives tale posing as fact the
mauler investigation itself batted down
BuzzFeed story almost immediately after
it came out
and yet BuzzFeed never retracted the
piece once again in its feline way to
say pretended that nothing had happened
you can yell at a cat but you can't make
a cat pay attention it turns out to be
clear here are the key quotes from the
January BuzzFeed story quote Trump
directed his longtime attorney Michael
Cohen to lie to Congress end quote and
again quote the president personally
instructed him to lie and quote and once
again quote it is the first known
example of Trump explicitly telling a
subordinate to lie directly about his
own dealings with Russia explicitly
telling a subordinate to lie that's the
claim okay Democratic members of
Congress asked Michael Cohen last week
about that specific claim Cohen was
under oath at the time a declared enemy
of Donald Trump not someone who had any
reason to lie about this here's how he
responded mr. Trump did not directly
tell me to lie to Congress that's not
how he operates okay let's let's try the
others make sure we've got this totally
clear Trump directed Michael Cohen to
lie he personally instructed him to lie
he quote explicitly told him twice those
are the claims from BuzzFeed did Michael
Cohen really do that here's his account
again did the president in any way from
your point of view coach you in terms of
how to respond to questions or the
content of your testimony before a House
committee again it's it's a difficult
answer because he doesn't tell you what
he wants what he does is again Michael
there's no Russia
there's no collusion there's no
involvement there's no interference I
know what he means because I've been
around him for so long
so if you're asking me whether or not
that's the message that's staying on
point that's the party line that he
created that so many others are
touting yes that's the message that he
wanted to reinforce that's the message
so Michael Cohen says you just heard him
say that Trump claimed there was no
Russian collusion and no interference in
the 2016 presidential election if that
sounds familiar it's because that's
exactly what Trump has been telling the
world for two years every day in a loud
voice to anyone who will listen
BuzzFeed claims that this is somehow
proof that its original story was
entirely accurate 19 adorable Siamese
kittens that are actually talented
investigative reporters we're waiting
for that story next